الحاجه فخريه ابو حصيره فلسطينيه تبلغ من
العمر 90 عاما نجت من مجزره استهدفت
عائلتها في حي الرمال شرقيه غزه تحكي
الحاجه فخريه ما عاشته بعد القصف وترفض
مغادره بيتها مهما كانت
الظروف والله يا ابني انا على هتخت قاعده
ما شفت اللي هالدنيا اطرب فوق راسي وين
اصرت اقول وين انا وين انا لا انا شايفه
ولا قاشه ولا شايفه وين اروح ولا كل ه
الردم اجي علي عتخت وانا مش شايفه حالي
اجوا الاولاد اولاد ابني اخذوني وطلعوني
برمله ب الحجار علي بحاله تعم بتعمل حاله
اللي نزلت لقيت الحاره نص شباب الحاره
بيته لقيت نص شباب
الحاره بنات ونسوان اولاد كلهم 200 يلا يا
راجل اللهلا معانا
[موسيقى]
يلا الله يفرجها علينا يا رب يا رب الله
حرام ه اللي بيعملوا فينا هذا حرام طفال
اللي عمره 10 ايام اللي عمره 40 يوم
المكسح اللي مقمل هي انا مره مكسحه بيتي
راح وداري راحت بدي الله يفرجها عليهم يا
رب جاه محمد يا رب حلوا علينا يا ملوك
العرب يلي قاعدين تتفرجوا علينا اتفرجوا
علينا تعالوا يحنوا علينا حنوا على
هالاطفال وهال الشباب اللي بتموت عمال بال
60 بال 70 واحد انتم مش مسلمين تعالوا
افزعوا نا تعالوا حلوا علينا يا ست والله
السقف واقع اقسم بالله السقف واقع لقيت اي
هوايه يا ستي بزل قال يا ستي خذ في
الاسباب السقف عندك واقع خشب مكان نزلنا ك
يا ستي بعين الله بحات عينين علي تنزل انا
من داري مش طالعه خلاص كلمه واسمعوها
والله يا ستي واجع والله واجع
خش